انطلقت قبل ساعات اعمال النسخه الثالثه من
منتدى الرياض الدولي الانسانيه بمشاركه
عدد من القاده والمانحيين والعاملين
والخبراء في مجال العمل الانساني وكيل
الامين العام للامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه مارتن جرافيث اكد خلال المنتدى
ان النظام العالمي يواجه تحديات وبحاجه
الى تعاون دولي من جهته قال المفاوض
السامي لشؤون اللاجئين فيليبو غراندي ان
تمويل المرن هو اهم عامل للتخطي الازمات
الحاليه في مجال الاغاثات وتستمر اعمال
المنتدى لمده يومين في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض
ومن هنا من الرياض انضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي اهلا بك عبد
المحسن اهم ما خرج به اليوم الاول من
منتدى الرياض الانساني
نعم راويه بالفعل قبل ساعات بدا هذا
المؤتمر بجلسه رفيعه المستوى شارك فيها
رؤساء منظمات دوليه انسانيه تابعه للامم
المتحده بالاضافه الى مركز الملك سلمان
بالاضافه الى الوزير عادل الجبير السعودي
الذي تحدث خلال هذه الجلسه عن عدد من
المحاور المختصه بالعمل الانساني وقال بان
السعوديه قدمت خلال 20 21 اكثر من سبعه
مليارات دولار كمساعدات ومنح لهذه
المنظمات الانسانيه التي تشارك بشكل كبير
جدا
بمستوى رفيع في هذا المؤتمر الذي انطلق
قبل ساعات وايضا قبل اقل من نصف ساعه بدات
جلسه الافتتاح لهذا المؤتمر بحضور وزير
الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان بالاضافه
الى مارتن جرافيت وكيل الامير العام لمنظم
للامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه بال الى
كافه المنظمات الامميه المشاركه في هذه
المنتدى ومنها منظمه صليب او صليب الاحمر
وكذلك الهجره منظمه الهجره الدوليه وعدد
من المنظمات التي تشارك في هذا المنتدى
لطرح عدد من المواضيع ربما ابرز ما تم
طرحه خلال الجلستين الاولى هو عمليه
التمويل ونقص التمويل لهذه المنظمات
والعمل الانساني بشكل كبير جدا والوصول
الى اكبر عدد ممكن من المحتاجين حول
العالم مارتنج رفد ذكر رقم بان 300 اكثر
من 330 مليون انسان حول العالم يحتاجون
لمساعدات بالاضافه الى ان
المساعدات
الحاليه او المنح المقدمه والمساهمات
الماليه لا تغطي الا ما يقارب 70% من
الاحتياج المالي فبالتالي عمليات المنح
والمطالبه
بالمساعدات بالاضافه عبد المحسن عدد الدول
المساهمه او عشر الدول